depuis le mois de septembre nous
construisons le budget de notre pays
pour 2023
en séance comment commission nous avons
eu des dizaines d'heures de débats nous
sommes allés le plus loin possible dans
les discussions dans l'hémicycle et des
amendements de la majorité comme des
oppositions ont été retenues
le texte que je vous présente est
similaire à celui qui a été adopté mardi
mais il a été enrichi et amélioré par
rapport à sa version initiale
au moment où ces débats se concluent je
vous propose un budget ambitieux
cohérent avec le choix réalisé par les
Français en avril et en juin dernier
c'est un budget qui honore les
engagements que nous avons pris devant
eux pas de hausse d'impôts des réponses
d'urgence pour le pouvoir d'achat des
moyens pour le plein emploi pour la
transition écologique pour l'égalité des
chances pour notre souveraineté je vous
propose un budget fait d'avancer
concrètes pour nos concitoyens pour
beaucoup
issus d'un travail parlementaire au-delà
des clivages je pense au filet de
sécurité simplifiés et élargi pour aider
les collectivités face à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie je pense à la demi
part des veuves des anciens combats
d'anciens combattants qui est une mesure
de justice
je pense à la revalorisation du salaire
des aesh à l'augmentation des moyens des
10 à la hausse de la dotation
biodiversité
la liste est encore longue des avancées
réalisées tout au long des débats
alors que nous serons demain au terme du
délai constitutionnel pour l'examen de
ce PLF alors que le temps de débat a été
contraint par la multiplication des
motions de censure nous devons avancer
nous devons prendre nos responsabilités
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
avons tenu nos engagements nos
engagements sur le fond en protégeant
les Français et en préparant l'avenir
nos engagements sur la méthode en
cherchant la concertation à chaque étape
depuis les dialogues de Bercy cet été
jusqu'à la discussion parlementaire que
nous avons laissé se tenir autant que
nous le pouvions nous avons connu des
avancées et je veux les saluer mais nous
avons aussi trop souvent trouvé
porte-close sur le budget nous ne
pouvons pas trouver de compromis si les
oppositions craignent ainsi de se
compromettre
[Applaudissements]
la France
la France a besoin d'un budget au
premier janvier 2023 et le temps presse
désormais aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi de finances pour 2023 je vous
remercie
je vous remercie l'assemblée nationale
prend acte de l'engagement de la
responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément au dispositions de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
le texte sur lequel la première ministre
engage la responsabilité du gouvernement
sera insérée en annexe au compte-rendu
de la présente séance en application de
l'article 155 à Lina premier du
règlement le débat sur le texte est
immédiatement suspendu ce texte sera
considéré comme adopté sauf une motion
de censure déposer demain avant
15h05 et voter dans les conditions
prévues à l'article 49 de la
Constitution dans l'hypothèse où émotion
de censure est déposée la Conférence des
Présidents fixera la date et les
modalités de sa discussion la séance est
suspendue